the universe is vast and full of Mystery
and one that has been puzzling
astronomers for a while now is fast
radio bursts and I mean I get it how am
I supposed to make this thing go fast or
burst nope luckily I have an astronomer
waiting for me in an elevator to explain
it all in the time it takes to go up to
the top and back down again let's go
thank you
hey Manisha hi rod
so I know we're talking space we're
talking astronomy we're talking fast
radio bursts that is correct all right
let's get into it
what is a fast radio burst fast radio
bursts or frbs as we refer to them are
these extremely energetic flashes in the
sky that last about a hundred times
quicker than the blink of an eye however
they're invisible to the naked eye
because they aim it at the range of
colors outside what the human eye can
perceive okay but where do they come
from now the furthest known frb was
produced 8 billion years ago and in
comparison our solar system is only 4.6
billion years old this means that when
the light left the source we did not
exist so the solar system the Earth life
on Earth humans we all came about while
the signal was traveling to us but wait
you said that it was light but it's not
light it's radio waves it's radio light
so it's not okay in the visible part of
the spectrum that you can see but
they're outside the red to blue rainbow
colors okay but what caused them could
it becomes
it is
we know of about 50 theories for what
these could be uh but the current
leading favorite are magnetos so these
are these extremely energetic objects
which have massive and Powerful magnetic
fields so what are the implications of
frbs like why do they matter what's
interesting is the signal there's the
imprint of the medium that it travels to
so the frb encodes information about
everything in its path so as a result
the Radio Data are a gold mine of
information and this in fact helped us
locate the missing matter in the
universe what do you mean missing metal
so 95 of the universe is dark energy and
dark matter and five percent is normal
matter but 50 of this normal matter is
only accounted for and the remaining 50
was considered missing until very
recently how is it missing how can we
just not know where it is it's matter so
in a sense it's invisible because it
doesn't emit or glow or absorb light but
it does slow down radio waves which is
where frvs come in have we found all of
it we have found all of it so it's
interesting with what we theorize but we
don't know how it's distributed there's
always a buzz there is always a butt
that's what research is well thank you
for teaching me about frbs so let me
start with what we do know fast radio
bursts are bursts of extremely energetic
radio waves think fem radio but way way
bigger and we kind of know where they
come from we have observed at least once
that they come from magnetize which are
a type of neutron star but other than
that we don't know what produces them
the other reason why they're really
interesting is we can use these fast
radio bursts to give us information
about matter in the universe and the way
that we do that is by comparing long and
short wave bursts that come from the
same origin point and calculate how long
it takes for them to arrive at us now
when they pass through matter that's
going to slow them down and depending on
the material it'll slow them down by a
different amount so we basically can
look at all of that and figure out
what's out there and in doing this we
have managed to find a whole lot of
matter that we just thought was missing
which is pretty cool I'm gonna be
thinking about that every time I listen
to the radio now hey there thanks for
watching if you liked this video you can
see more elevator pitch here or you
could subscribe below for more videos
from ABC science and if you're Keen to
uncover more cosmological Mysteries then
stream Catalyst on ABC iview
[Music]